[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
jetzt leben wir über die anpassungen der
pauschalen durchschnitts besteuerung von
landwirtschaftlichen umsetzen
dieses gesetz ist seine pflicht keine
kühe es geht allein dazu eine der
vermutlich noch zahlreichen zeilen
kartoffeln aus der regierungszeit von
cdu und csu zu entsorgen und zwar so zu
entsorgen dass sie keinen milliarden
schweren schaden für unsere landwirte
anrichtet seit jahren gibt es nämlich
einen intensiven streit zwischen der
eu-kommission und dem cdu-geführten
landwirtschaftsministerium worum geht es
die eu kommission kritisiert dass
deutschland eine besondere ausnahme in
der umsatzbesteuerung nämlich die
möglichkeit die umsätze pauschal nach
durchschnitten zu besteuern um
bürokratie zu sparen dass deutschland
diese ausnahme in der landwirtschaft zur
regel gemacht hat und zwar nicht um
einfach von bürokratie zu entlasten
sondern um damit die landwirtschaft
zusätzlich zu subventionieren die
kommission hat deswegen nicht nur ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren gegen
deutschland eingeleitet
die eu kommission hat bereits anfang
2020 also vor fast zwei jahren eine
klage beim europäischen gerichtshof
wegen unzulässiger beihilfen eingereicht
und das heißt im zweifel drohen den
deutschen landwirten rückzahlungen in
höhe von zwei milliarden euro auf diese
summe schätzt jedenfalls die kommission
die uns und des wegen beihilfe der
deutschen landwirtschaft über die
letzten zehn jahre aber die cdu/csu
szene august und auch mal aus rein
wahlkampftaktischen gründen und
fahrlässig eine tragfähige gesetzliche
korrektur dieser regelung über
eineinhalb jahre verhindert und deshalb
müssen wir uns jetzt nach der wahl auf
den wirklich alle drücker noch mit dem
konstituierung prozess und ohne gewählte
entschuldigungen frau bitte kollegin
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn sie
sich fröhlich unterhalten wollen spricht
nichts dagegen aber bitte nicht hier im
raum
[Applaus]
das hat es uns jetzt mit diesem gesetz
beschäftigen ohne gewählte regierung ich
finde das ist wirklich grotesk mal damen
und herren
den bundesrat hat die liste setzt jetzt
nach der wahl auch ohne großes
federlesen mit den stimmen der cdu auch
in erster lesung passiert und was steht
drin vor allem soll nun der durchsatz
der umsatzbesteuerung mit dem
vorliegenden gesetz von 10,7 auf 9,5
prozent abgesenkt werden darüber hinaus
wird die berechnungsformel diese
kalkulationen des durchschnitts satzes
dienst gesetzlich festgelegt und damit
greift der gesetzentwurf eine empfehlung
des bundesrechnungshofs auf der übrigens
die geltenden bestimmungen der
durchschnitts besteuerung auch schon
bereits 2015 als europarechtswidrig
kritisierte die absenkung des durch
steuersatzes bedeutet wohl 95 millionen
euro weniger für die landwirte und ja es
wird auch wieder diejenigen treffen die
heute schon um ihr überleben kämpfen
aber eine milliarden rückzahlung ist
wirklich leider nicht die bessere
alternative mal damen und herren
[Applaus]
die einkommenssituation vieler
landwirtschaftlicher betriebe ist
aktuell wirklich äußerst schwierig
insbesondere bei den tierhaltenden
betriebe gerade die kleinen und regional
verankerten betriebe müssten aber
erhalten bleiben wenn wir den umbau der
landwirtschaft zu mehr nachhaltigkeit
und regionale erzeugung voranbringen
wollen die entwicklung ist wirklich
dramatisch seit 2010 gegen die zahl der
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe um 13
prozent zurück die zahl der 4 betriebe
insgesamt seien in der gleichen zeit
sogar um 22 prozent und bei den
milchviehbetrieben war die entwicklung
noch einmal dramatisch ein minus von 40
prozent
umgekehrt entwickelte sich aber der
konzentrationsprozess seit 2010 die
durchschnittliche zahl der milchkühe
betrieb von 46 auf
72 milchkühe pro betrieb und die
durchschnittliche zahl der schweine pro
betrieb stieg von
460 auf
826 tiere also auf fast das doppelte in
derselben zeit insbesondere kleine
betriebe brauchen daher dringend unsere
unterstützung und pragmatische lösung
meine damen und herren
und hierzu gehört aus unserer sicht auch
dass wir der umgehung der
grunderwerbsteuer bescherte ist endlich
gesetzlich einen riegel vorschieben bei
damen und herren capital investoren die
spekulation von hedgefonds abend in den
vergangenen jahren zu erheblichen
preissteigerungen von ackerland und pack
geführt steuerfreier schärding sind mit
grundbesitz spielen dabei eine
erhebliche rolle sie zerstören eine
breite eigentums streuung in der
landwirtschaft sie führen zur
verdrängung von bäuerliche und
ökologisch wirtschaftenden betrieben zu
gunsten von agrar holding ohne
verankerung in der region und wir von
den grünen wollen deshalb diese
steuerschlupfloch scherlies
schnellstmöglich schließen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
soweit lisa paus hier von den grünen in
der debatte zu den unionsrechtlichen
vorgaben im
umsatzsteuerrecht wie sollen landwirte
von der umsatzsteuer befreit werden oder
eben nicht darum geht es jetzt sarah
ricklefs key spricht jetzt die
parlamentarische staatssekretärin beim
bundesministerium für finanzen immer
noch geschäft wird
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ja jetzt
wird es wieder etwas technisch di
finanza kommen wir befassen uns heute in
erster lesung mit dem entwurf eines
gesetzes zur umsetzung unionsrechtlichen
vorgaben im umsatzsteuerrecht und dieses
gesetz enthält in der tat zwei
regelungen die vor dem hintergrund des
und munz rechts eben noch vor jahresende
umzusetzen sind und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir heute hier in dieser
debatte den gesetzentwurf einbringen und
dann auch weiter beraten ja das ganze
hier diskutieren das klingt sehr
technisch auch die erste maßnahme die
wir umsetzen
klingt in der tat noch technischer es
geht um die steuer vergütung für
leistungen zur bekämpfung der coop 19
pandemie aber sie hören schon an der
bezeichnung es geht tatsächlich auch
hier um ein thema und das thema was uns
alle sehr intensiv beschäftigt und es
geht tatsächlich auch um die frage wie
wir diese krise auch innerhalb europas
lösen und da ist ganz klar wir möchten
sie solidarischen müssen hier geht es
darum dass steuervergütung
wenn europäische einrichtungen in
deutschland leistungen zu bekämpfen mit
19 pandemie beziehen da geht es
beispielsweise und beatmungsgeräte und
andere spezialisierte behandlung
mechanismen diese leistung unentgeltlich
an dritte weitergereicht werden weiter
reichen dann ist das gemeinsame
verständnis der mitgliedstaaten dass
hier nicht die nationalen pisten davon
profitieren sollen sondern dass
grundsätzlich auch die anfallende
umsatzsteuer
verzichtet wird und das ist glaube ich
eine lösung die richtig und gut ist und
die auch dazu beiträgt dass wir hier
gemeinsam auch gut aus der krise kommen
ganz praktisch bedeutet das dass sich
europäische einrichtungen wenn sie
entsprechende gegenstände erwerben die
hierfür gezahlte umsatzsteuer vom fiskus
erstatten lassen können das schafft dann
eben auch die nötigen spenden oder
zusätzliche finanzielle spielräume bei
der bekämpfung der coop 19 wenn solche
gegenstände aus dem drittland nach
deutschland geliefert werden dann ist
sie ein vorsteuer befreit also auch hier
eine saubere lösung und ich denke wir
sind uns alle einig dass es nicht nur
aufgrund der unionsrechtlichen vorgaben
sind macht das jetzt zeitnah umzusetzen
sondern weil es eine sinnvolle regelung
ist
[Applaus]
der zweite kommt das hat die kollegen in
dieser pause schon vorgestellt ist die
umsatzbesteuerung gelernt wird konkret
die durchschnitts besteuerung der
landwirte das hat uns in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode in der tat häufiger
beschäftigt hier geht es ganz praktisch
darum dass man für kleinere
landwirtschaftliche betriebe eine
vereinfachungsregelung vorsieht und auch
da ist es in der tat erst mal so dass es
eine sinnvolle maßnahme ist die sieht
nämlich vor dass landwirte für bezogene
leistungen kein vorsteuerabzug zusteht
sie bekommen vom finanzamt die
umsatzsteuer auf ihre eingangsleistung
also nicht erstattet aber sie dürfen bei
ihren rechnungen umsatzsteuer ausweisen
und vereinnahmen und müssen diese dann
jedoch nicht an den fiskus abführen
die einbehaltenen umsatzsteuer
kompensiert also die fehlenden den
vielen vorsteuerabzug und der
prozentsatz der angibt in welchem höhe
land heute in ihren rechnungen
umsatzsteuer ausweisen dürfen das ist
eben der genannte durchschnittssatz und
in der tat ist es so wenn dieser
durchschnittssatz zu hoch ist dann
erfolgt eine überkompensation denn die
landwirte nehmen dann mehr umsatzsteuer
ein als ihnen über den fehlenden
vorsteuerabzug entgeht und das ist in
der tat so und das ist der gegenstand
und der grund weshalb welche diskutieren
das verstößt gegen das unionsrecht und
deswegen müssen welche abhilfe schaffen
derzeit beträgt er durch das salz 10,7
prozent
richtigerweise dürfte er nach den
aktuellen daten und der anzuwendenden
berechnungsmethode jedoch nur 9 5
prozent betragen und daher möchten wir
den durchschnittssatz auf diese höhe
anpassen mit dem vorliegenden
gesetzentwurf ich darf in diesem
zusammenhang auch darauf hinweisen dass
wir hier wirklich handeln müssen weil
wegen der höhe des durchschnitts satzes
sowohl ein vertragsverletzungsverfahren
auch als ein beihilfeverfahren gegen
deutschland existiert und wir eben
schauen müssen dass wir hier möglichen
rückforderungsansprüche auch in unsere
landwirte an unsere landwirte in
milliarden-höhe sonst damit konfrontiert
werden und deswegen ist das auch wenn
das sicherlich für die landwirte auch
erst mal eine sache es mit der sie
werden umgehen müssen ist es richtig
dass wir hier so handeln
[Applaus]
und damit das verfahren auch in zukunft
noch mal sicherer ist und auch
rechtssicherer ist es so dass wir in dem
gesetzentwurf zusätzlich noch drin
stehen haben dass das bundesministerium
der finanzen die höhe des durchschnitts
satzes in zukunft jährlich überprüft und
danach jährlich dem gesetzgeber
berichten soll und bei bedarf eben eine
anpassung des gesetzentwurfs zur
anpassung des durchsatzes vorlegt ich
glaube damit sind wir gut aufgestellt
und geben auch in seinem dritten eine
gute perspektive vielen dank
[Applaus]
sarik lewski war das hier noch einmal
die problematik erläutert warum jetzt
auch handlungsbedarf besteht weil eben
aus der eu kommission ist ankündigungen
gibt hier alle vor das gericht zu ziehen
ob es hier vertragsnationen von
deutscher seite ausgabe antje tillmann
spricht jetzt als nächstes für die
unionsfraktion
insbesondere liebe kollegen der
eventuell künftigen koalition nicht eine
einzige vollständige sitzungswoche haben
sie abgewartet um das erste
steuererhöhungs gesetz dieser künftigen
koalition auf den weg zu bringen
liebe kollegen der fdp ihr habt nicht
eine woche stand gehalten noch bevor der
koalitionsvertrag unterschrieben wurde
macht er die erste steuererhöhungen da
lässt man manches tarnen und ich will
mal nicht davon ich will mal nicht davon
ausgehen dass sie dem dach haben weil
der durchschnittssteuersatz von 10,7 auf
595 dem welt wird dass es sich um eine
steuersenkung heißt denn sie wissen ja
sehr wohl dass durch das system der
durchschnitts besteuerung die
steuersenkung zu einer zusätzlichen
belastungen der landwirte fühlt
und es ist wahr dass die europäische
kommission die steuersenkung angemahnt
hat das ist so das wissen auch wir
deshalb hat er auch das
finanzministerium im sommer des letzten
jahres eine absenkung auf 9,6 prozent
vorgelegt der zwischenzeit haben wir
erheblich landwirtschaftliche betriebe
aus der bemessungsgrundlage und der
begünstigung der durchschnitts
besteuerung rausgenommen mit dem
jahressteuergesetz 2020 dürfen landwirte
mit dem umsatz von 600.000 gar nicht
pauschalieren warum dann aber der
steuersatz des bmf heute vorschlägt mit
9,5 auch noch niedriger ist obwohl wir
weniger begünstigte haben das werden wir
uns am montag in der anhörung sehr
intensiv erklären lassen das konnte uns
bisher keiner tatsächlich transparent
machen und man könnte meinen 0,1 prozent
das ist auch kleinigkeit aber das sind 8
millionen euro für die landwirte und
landwirtinnen und das wollen wir
hinterfragen am montag
es ist dem referentenentwurf ja noch
schlimmer geworden nicht nur dass die
zahlen nicht transparent gemacht werden
sondern es wird deutlich dass auch das
finanzministerium in zukunft das
parlament eher als lästig empfindet denn
es hatte vorgesehen dass die künftigen
anpassungen des pauschal satzes
automatisch erfolgen sollen allein durch
bmf schreiben eines ministers dass der
tarif auf rädern liebe fdp kollegen
verdienen so gemeint war dass es zu
steuererhöhungen automatisch führt bei
mir bisher nicht klar aber sie werden es
mehr ja bestimmt gleich erklären können
unsere landwirtschaftsministerin
klöckner hat das abdrucken bisschen wir
werden jedes mal wieder im parlament
darüber diskutieren müssen und wir
werden uns die zahlen jeweils vorrechnen
lassen insgesamt ist dieser erste
gesetzentwurf aber natürlich ein
schlechtes omen für die zukunft denn
wenn ich mir die sondierung papiere und
die diskussion von ihnen angehöre es
gibt weder eine vorsorge für die
reduzierte besteuerung der renten noch
gibt es eine maßnahme die
steuererstattung zinssätze zu reduzieren
beides vorgaben des verfassungsgerichtes
und liebe fdp sie haben auch im
sondierungs papier keine vorsorge für
die kalte progression getroffen in dem
jahr in dem es erste mal die produktion
wieder auswirkungen hat nämlich fast
vier milliarden euro für die bürgerinnen
und bürger haben sie nicht
sichergestellt dass sie neutralisiert
wird das wird die nächste
steuererhöhungen die sie in diesem haus
beschließen werden das werden wir ihnen
nicht durchgehen lassen wir werden sie
ermahnen und ihnen ihre wahlprogramme
vorhalten und dann nützt es auch gar
nichts dass eventuell ein fdp-minister
diese verordnung schließt wir brauchen
die parlamentarische kontrolle und die
werden sie garantiert von uns auch in
der opposition bekommen
manche themen hat hier schon angekündigt
auch die union stellt sich auf ihre
rolle als opposition ein
tillmanns man spricht jetzt für die fdp
fraktion als muss jetzt noch kurz das
pult nach jedem redner hier desinfiziert
werden
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin geschätzte
kolleginnen und kollegen dass wir heute
noch vor bildung der neuen
bundesregierung hier über dieses thema
umsatzsteuerpauschalierung für landwirte
sprechen müssen ist offensichtlich ein
versäumnis das seine wurzeln ja bereits
im jahr 2013 hatte und sich über die
letzte legislaturperiode dann noch
weiter angestaut hat und frau kollegin
tillmann sie haben da sehr sehr schnell
auch opposition umgeschaltet
2013 wurden die wurzeln im bmf das von
der cdu geführt wurde gelegt das ist ein
problem das haben sie die ganze zeit
produziert und und weiter ausgebaut und
heute müssen wir es einfach regeln
in aller kürze
wir müssen das jetzt in letzter minute
vor jahreswechsel abschließen um schaden
vom deutschen fiskus aber auch von den
betroffenen landwirtschaftlichen
betrieben abzuwenden im kern geht es
darum dass sie der vergangenheit die
pauschalierung zu hoch war so dass man
die regelung als
unzulässige beihilfe werden musste das
hat uns nicht nur die eu kommission so
gesagt sondern auch unser eigener
bundesrechnungshof aber auf die frage
meines kollegen gero hocker in einer
kleinen anfrage im september 2020 ob die
bundesregierung eine anpassung des
pauschalierung satzes plane hat die
bundesregierung vor gerade in einem jahr
noch eindeutig mit nein geantwortet man
habe der kommission die
berechnungsmethoden und datenquellen
ausführlich dargelegt und erläutert und
heute sehen wir die bundesregierung war
damit einfach auf dem holzweg jetzt ist
die zeit knapp geworden
jetzt ist die zeit sehr knapp geworden
das ist aber kein grund auf die
ordentliche parlamentarische befassung
zu verzichten wird er jetzt noch bei der
zukünftigen nötigen regelmäßigen nutzt
neufestsetzung des sanierungs satzes ich
freue mich ausdrücklich dann auf die
expertenanhörung wo wir im interesse der
betroffenen landwirte auch noch mal über
die berechnung gerade in der
übergangszeit der ersten drei jahre
sprechen müssen eine generelle anmerkung
pauschalierungen leiden immer unter
gewissen unsicherheiten bei ihrer
festsetzung sie sind aber immer noch ein
sehr wichtiges instrument um ausufernde
bürokratie einzudämmen
ein anderes auch ergänzendes instrument
kann es sein
das verfahren an sich zu modernisieren
viele probleme kommen noch aus der zeit
als man steuerbelastung noch auf papier
ausrechnen oder papierformulare
eintragen musste unser steuersystem ist
immer noch nicht möglich und digitalen
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert angekommen
gerade auch bei der umsatzsteuer und
frau kollege tillmann das lag auch an
den letzten sechzig 16 jahren ihre
da sind viele unserer nachbarländer wo
sie die kleinere deutlich weiter auch
was die umsatzsteuer betrifft frankreich
italien tschechien zum beispiel jetzt in
deutschland weitere vier jahre zu warten
und die 20 voll zu machen dass das
abwarten so nichtstuns bis wir den
anschluss gefunden haben an das
internationale feld das wäre ein großer
fehler
lasst uns mit hilfe elektronischer
rechnungen oder digitale übermittlung
und kontrollverfahren gerade unsere
kleinen und mittelständischen betriebe
von bürokratie entlasten auch kleine und
mittlere landwirtschaftliche betriebe
die wir jetzt leider belastet und
verunsichert haben würden davon schnell
profitieren die menschen die dort
arbeiten sollen sich doch mehr
eigentliches geschäft kümmern und nicht
um bürokratie
bei dieser gelegenheit sollten wir auch
noch einmal auf den durch die pandemie
deutlich verstärkte fristen ballungen im
nächsten dreiviertel jahr aufmerksam
machen das sollten wir auch nicht
zuletzt zur entlastung der
steuerfachleute noch mal genau
hinschauen
und im landwirtschaftlichen bild zu
bleiben wollen wir nun in diesem jahr
noch die kuh vom eis was die frage der
pauschalierung angeht und ab dem
nächsten jahr schmelzen wir dann das eis
der bürokratie in diesem land generell
ab in diesem sinne
freue ich mich auf die arbeit der
nächsten jahre
das stimmt natürlich der beweis und
hauptausschuss zu vielen dank
till mansmann war das hier zum
umsatzsteuerrecht er saß auch in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode im
finanzausschuss und auch der nächste
redner kennt sich wohl mit dem thema
sehr gut aus klaus stöber ist nicht nur
mitglied der fdp-fraktion sondern von
beruf auch steuerberater
[Applaus]
im vergleich zu den bisherigen
tagesordnungspunkten migration und
infektionsschutzgesetz klingt dieses
thema das war recht fade und wenig vom
wenig präsent wird gebildet aber muss ja
sagen für die betroffenen landwirte ist
hat es doch schon eine hohe präsenz
die antwort erhalten natürlich auch
subventionen aus der eu aber ich denke
mal keine andere branche in deutschland
ist von dem verordnungsweg der eu so
geprägt wie unser land worte hier in
deutschland und das trägt diese neue
regelung trägt dazu bei in dieser
neuregelung für das optionsrecht der
landwirte zu deutschlands gestorben
nochmals erheblich eingeschränkt das
wohl der stadt erläutert das anfang des
jahres diese können so schon 600.000
reduziert wurde was ich neben diesen 95
millionen
ausgaben für die land wurde
bemängelt dass schüler angesprochen
worden dass diese regelung aus den
vierten oktober 2021 den verbänden
vorgelegt wurde jetzt am ersten hustons
weiter 22 euro schule in kraft treten
das heißt also die verbände hatten
überhaupt nicht die möglichkeit ihre
land wurde zu informieren und auch über
gestaltungsvorschläge sondern richten
und das beratungsbedarf da vorhanden ist
das will ich ihnen auch gerne erläutern
jeder landwirt muss an zehnten januar
das e mails bei der praxis am 10 januar
eines jahres erklären ob er zur
regelbesteuerung unser special sturm
optiert und da muss eine entscheidung
treffen heißt es ist eine investition ja
investitionen die nächsten zwei jahre
hand und auch investitionen die in den
letzten fünf jahren durch genommen hat
weil er letztendlich dazu deutschen
gestorben optiert dann kein anspruch
mehr hat auch vorsteuererstattung für
diese wirtschaftsgüter und ich denke mal
das ist das problem das viele einfache
haben dass sie ganz einfach jetzt von
heute auf morgen vor allem nationen
gestellt werden und letztlich sollten
wir doch parteiübergreifend hier im
bundestag dafür sorgen dass wir das
steuerrecht für alle bürger für alle
unternehmen zu einfach und verständlich
und planbar gestalten sollen und das ist
gerade das nicht der fall und wie so
eine regelung von heute auf morgen
einfach den landwirten aufdrücken und
der kollegen arts hat ja mal die
[Musik]
august regierung gebrauchte artikel
steuererklärung sicherlich lässt sich
die steuererklärung des landbrot ist
nicht auf einen bierdeckel transpirieren
aber diese gesetzesänderung hat dazu
beigetragen dass die bürokratie gerade
für ein land erheblich eingeschränkt
worden mit der neuregelung wird diese
einschränkung etwas zurückgenommen das
muss man einfach feststellen und das
endlich müssen wir zusammen fassen
feststellen auch wenn das sicherlich
hier in dem häuser nicht gern gehört
wird das wieder einmal europarecht vor
deutsches recht gestellt wird ja wir
haben wir leben jetzt praktisch die
vorgaben der eu die uns hier auf gesenkt
wurden um unser land wurde in
deutschland wirtschaftlich zu schädigen
aber das kann man das nicht nennen und
dieser gesetzesentwurf sei ein
paradebeispiel dafür wie die eu in
deutsches recht ein kraft- und hier zu
lasten der deutschen bauern das muss man
auch mal wirklich sagen
hätte genügend
aufgabenfelder hierfür eine
vereinheitlichung in europa zu sorgen
ich denke mal zum beispiel einen
radlader in europa eine einheitliche
bedingungen für die nutztierhaltung aber
nein da war nichts übernommen sondern es
wird hier eine regelung gefunden die
wieder einmal deutschland wurden
zu genüge belastet werde deswegen sagen
wir
leben diese regelung ab auch wenn es die
europarechtlich vorgegeben ist
eigentlich einfach diese übergangsphase
um für den oktober bis zum einfachsten
zwölften die landwirte nicht verkauft
bildern
klaus stöber war das für die afg
fraktion auf ihn folgt jetzt christian
görke mitglied der linksfraktion hier im
deutschen bundestag
so präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ich vor meiner ersten rede
dieses unterschwellige eu bashing dieser
hobby patrioten der afg anhören musste
das ist wahrscheinlich hier gang und
gäbe aber für mich erstmal
gewöhnungsbedürftig zur sache in das
problem liebe kolleginnen kollegen liegt
auf dem tisch und
ist symptomatisch für die schlafwagen
politik der letzten jahre reformen über
reform wurden vergeigt oder ausgesessen
so auch hier erst nachdem nun mal der
bundesrechnungshof den finger gehoben
hat und deutschland nun eine eu klage
hat am hals hat da wird gehandelt und
die probleme mit der pauschalisierung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sind ja
längst bekannt und die reform wie gesagt
hätten schon früh angegangen werden
müssen eine lösung zu finden die
praktikabel ist und vor allen dingen die
die praxis derart schafften landwirte
irgendwie abbildet und liebe kollegin
tillmann ich glaube ihr die amtierende
bundesregierung hat diesen gesetzentwurf
jetzt im oktober beschlossen und
insofern verstehe ich ja ihre kritik nun
überhaupt nicht was jetzt vorliegt ist
vielleicht jetzt
klage beständig aber handwerklich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen bekämen
landwirte aber finanzpolitiker wirklich
schlecht gemacht und ich will aus
zeitgründen auf zwei sachen eingehen
erstens wird gerade den kleinen
landwirten durch diesen niedrigen
steuersatz in die kasse gegriffen denn
dieser porsche jungs satz fällt nämlich
deshalb nur so niedrig aus weil in der
berechnung die großen die profitablen
firmen nicht mehr drin sind denn sie
sind ja nach der neuen puzzle die
pauschalisierung regel aus der
umsatzsteuer bei 600.000 raus aus dem
geschäft eisen die berechnung ist falsch
oder nehmen wir zweitens die umsetzung
zum ersten januar diese völlig
realitätsfremd weil das wirtschaftsjahr
für land und forstwirtschaft schon ist
es gesagt waren im juli beginnt heißt
berufs chaos und mehrkosten
vorprogrammiert und liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen das sage nicht ich sagen
die fachverbände und ich muss wirklich
sagen ein tag beteiligung in einem
gesetzgebungsverfahren
das ist ja kein bundesliga niveau oder
bundestags in die wohn insofern meine
damen und herren ist mit diesem
gesetzentwurf in großen teilen
handwerklich schlecht gearbeitet
brauchen und das werden wir im
hauptausschuss nacharbeiten vielen dank
vielen dank herr kollege
für die spd fraktion erhält jetzt das
wort die kollegin jenny pippal tippe
[Applaus]
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen seit ein paar wochen führen wir
intensive koalitionsverhandlungen und
auch wenn wir wirklich sehr sehr gut
vorankommen gibt es im punkte die wir
nicht aufschieben können bis zur
regierungsbildung und dazu zählt die
umsatzsteuer sonderregel für unsere
landwirtinnen und landwirte die
pauschalbesteuerung
diese regel ist so alt wie unsere
mehrwertsteuersystem und vor allem für
landwirte mit kleinen und mittleren
betrieben von großer bedeutung und
wichtig und wir stehen als
spd-bundestagsfraktion auch zu der
pauschalbesteuerung sie gibt es auch in
vielen anderen eu-ländern
was wir allerdings ändern müssen ist die
höhe des steuersatzes der muss sich nach
eu recht nämlich an der allgemeinen
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung orientieren
und in deutschland ist der
durchschnittliche steuersatz zu lange
seit 2013 nicht angepasst worden und das
führt im schnitt dazu dass teilweise
umsatzsteuer mehr vereinnahmt wird als
vorsteuer gezahlt wird kritik an den
veralteten steuersätzen gibt der
bundesrechnungshof bereits seit sechs
jahren auch die kommission kritisiert
die fehlende anpassungen sie hat
mittlerweile ein
vertragsverletzungsverfahren und ein
beihilfeverfahren eingeleitet es drohen
rückforderungen für die landwirte in
höhe von rund zwei milliarden euro und
genau das wollen wir verhindern
und 1 will ich hier auch klarstellen in
dieser situation sind wir gekommen weil
sich die union als vermeintlichen
schutzpatron
der landwirte aufgespielt hat ein
schauspiel das am ende eben diese
landwirte ausbaden müssen das riskieren
sie zuletzt hatte das finanzministerium
noch vor der sommerpause versucht das
vertragsverletzungsverfahren mit eben
diesem gesetz abzuwenden ohne erfolg
denn aus wahltaktischen gründen wollte
die cdu csu fraktion das nicht das muss
auch mal gesagt werden
und warnte und meine der agrarpolitische
sprecher kollege steht stegemann von der
vor schnellschüssen und regte eine
angehende prüfung an ähnlich der kollege
straubinger der das ziel der abschaffung
der pauschalierung unterstellte all das
was wir hingegen wollen
verantwortungsvolle politik für unser
land für unsere landwirte machen
mit dem vorliegenden gesetz streben wir
daher eine einstellung des
vertragsverletzungsverfahren ein und das
müssen wir noch bis ende des jahres
machen und deshalb debattieren wir hier
heute da geht es eben darum den
durchschnittssteuersatz abzusenken aber
auch wollen wir künftig eine schnellere
und eine transparentere anpassung eine
jährliche anpassung der vorliegende
gesetzesentwurf enthält auch dieses neue
verfahren die geschäftsführende
bundesregierung konnte sich leider
darauf nicht einigen daher freue ich
mich sehr auf die gemeinsamen gespräche
mit den grünen und der fdp in diesem
zusammenhang wir können gemeinsam zeigen
dass eine neue koalition dieses problem
dauerhaft aus der welt schafft wir
wollen schaden von unseren landwirten ab
wenn
das ich bin überzeugt davon dass wir mit
ihrem gesetzt einen ersten erfolg der
kommenden koalition in der steuerpolitik
erreichen könnten vielen dank
denn dank kollegen
als letzter redner
für die cdu csu fraktion
erhält das wort der kollege fritz
güntzler bitteschön
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren es ist schon spannend mal wieder
eine steuerpolitische debatte zu führen
und auch die verteilten rollen zu
erleben ist schon
reflexartig die fdp reagierte nachdem
frau tillmann zu recht darauf
hingewiesen hat dass mit dem diesem
gesetz das steht sogar einen
gesetzentwurf an steuererhöhungen
verbunden ist und wer diesem gesetz
zustimmt wird letztlich einer
steuererhöhung zustimmen und wenn man
draußen darstellt wir wollen keine
steuererhöhungen dann ist es halt so und
die aufgeregtheit zeigt ja auch dass die
fdp noch nicht so ganz angekommen ist
und frau aus wenn sie dazwischen rufe
ich möchte auch zu ihrer rede sagen sie
haben wieder den eindruck erweckt dass
die besteuerung nach durch schnitzen
setzen bei den landwirten eine
subvention ist das ist es definitiv
nicht diese sonderregelung gibt es seit
1968 frau dttb hat darauf hingewiesen
sie ist in der mehrwertsteuer licht in
dir so angelegt und wenn sie
funktioniert ist sie richtig weil das
ziel ja ist das durch den
durchschnittssatz die vorsteuer
belastung aller pauschal landwirte
portionieren landwirte in deutschland
ausgeglichen wird dass der zusätzliche
erlöst in der landwirt über die
umsatzsteuer er field soll die
finanzielle belastung der vorsteuer
abdecken das ist der kern der regelung
und wenn das funktioniert ist die
zahllast 0 und dann ist auch alles gut
wir haben jetzt einen strittigen punkt
und daran ist das verfahren auch um so
viel zur geschichte gescheitert beim
steueroasen abwehr gesetzt weil wir bis
jetzt nicht vorgelegt bekommen haben wie
die berechnung dieses satzes von 9,6 im
tatsächlichen durchgeführt werden das
bmf liefert hier einfach nicht und dass
unsere aufgabe auch wenn es ein entwurf
der bundesregierung ist als parlament da
genau hinzuschauen und ich will wissen
wo kommt diese zahl her wie ist sie
berechnet worden der kollege der linken
hat sich auf dieses problem hingewiesen
und dann gibt es nachholbedarf und die
regierung hat ja die chance im
gesetzgebungsverfahren jetzt das einfach
mal vorzulegen dann ist es ja richtig in
dem moment wo der satz zu hoch ist gibt
es eine überkompensation sprich
vielleicht eine beihilfe umkehrschluss
ist natürlich wenn der satz so niedrig
ist gibt es eine zu hohe belastung der
landwirte also von daher müssen wir uns
das schon genau angucken es gibt den
verdacht dass der satz zu niedrig ist
weil im verfahren und der in der
berechnung ein großer fehler da ist das
vertragsverletzung und beihilfe
verfahren ist ja angesprochen worden wir
haben mit dem jahressteuergesetz 20 20
den anwendungsbereich vermindert weil
nur noch landwirte bis zu einem umsatz
von 600.000 euro die pauschalierung
wählen können aber in den statistischen
unterlagen die anscheinend wir haben es
ja nicht vorliegen der unterhalt der
berechnung zugrunde gelegen haben ist
das nicht berücksichtigt worden und es
ist die vermutung dass gerade die großen
landwirte rausfallen mit größeren
beträgen oder kleineren belegt also von
daher brauchen wir konkrete zahlen damit
wir das auch wirklich gegenüber den
landwirten vertreten können denn es geht
im wesentlichen frau sollte auch und
hier im so seien um die kleinen
bäuerlichen betriebe für die sich
angeblich immer so einsetzen hier haben
sie die chance etwas zu tun und sie
versagen auf ganzer linie vor 1000
also von daher haben wir unserer
verantwortung als parlamentarier
wahrscheinlich alle positionen gerecht
wenn wir uns die dinge die die
bundesregierung hier vorgelegt hat sehr
genau angucken werden natürlich wollen
wir ein beihilfeverfahren wir wollen
keine rückzahlung über zehn jahre von
zwei milliarden euro erzeugt aber wir
wollen solide zahlen damit wir den
landwirten offen gegenübertreten können
und ich bin schon verwundert wenn ich
einen kollegen haben es mal jemand von
der fdp hier gehört habe der geht
eindruck erweckt hat dass man die
durchschnitts besteuerung abschaffen
will also dass wenn ich eine spannende
gesagt geschichte die sollten sie mit
ihrem landwirtschaftlichen politiker er
einen hocker mal aus niedersachsen wir
sprechen ich glaube da fahren wir da
nicht begeistert sein herzlichen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]